[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of harry potter theory
in today's video we're going to once
again be discussing
hogwarts lovable game keeper rubius
hagrid more specifically
we're going to be discussing hagrid's
love life and what came of its
blossoming relationship
with madame maxime it all started with
the tri-wizard tournament
the triwizard tournament was first
established some 700 years ago
as a friendly competition between the
three largest european schools of
wizardry
hogwarts bobaton and durmstrang the
schools took it in turns to host the
tournament once every five years
and it was generally agreed to be a most
excellent way
of establishing ties between young
witches and wizards of different
nationalities and established ties the
tournament certainly did
however this did not only apply to the
younger demographic
furthermore some of these ties
transcended friendship and escalated
into love
madame olimpe maxim was a french witch
and headmistress of bobaton academy of
magic
she was 11 feet 6 inches tall and a half
giant
just like hagrid when maxime arrived at
hogwarts along with her cohort of young
witches
she immediately caught hagrid's eye from
right near the beginning of maxim's
arrival
hagrid and her seem to cozy up to one
another hagrid may have been more
conspicuous about his enamelment
but the feeling was mutual at least to
some extent
they couldn't hear what hagrid was
saying but he was talking to madame
maxime
with a wrapped misty-eyed expression
hagrid also didn't quite know what to
say to her
and at one point accidentally insulted
her by referring to her
half-giant status how dare you shrieked
madame maxime
her voice exploded through the peaceful
night air like a foghorn
behind him harry heard fleur and roger
fall out of their rose bush
i have never been more insulted in my
life half giant
moi i have i have big bones
though hagrid inadvertently insulted
maxime the pair did eventually kiss and
make
up travelling together to visit the
giant colonies as envoys for dumbledore
apart from the book's initial signifiers
that the pair were possibly romantically
linked
the relationship isn't touched on much
and eventually the goblet of fire simply
ends
with maxime departing and heading back
to bobaton
alone this left fans with one big
question what happened with hagrid and
maxime
did they rekindle their love later in
life were they in correspondence during
their time apart
rowling once addressed hagrid's love
life in an interview
did hagrid ever get married and have
children oh did howard ever get married
and have children
no realistically hagrid's pool of
potential girlfriends is extremely
limited
because with the giants killing each
other off the number of giant asses
around is infinitesimal and he met one
of the only ones
and i'm afraid she thought he was kind
of cute that she was a little more
how should i put it sophisticated than
hagrid so no
bless him so it turned out that maxime
simply thought she was too good for
hagrid
however it's also worth mentioning that
the pair didn't part on bad terms
as indicated by their behavior at
dumbledore's funeral
harry watched from a window as a
gigantic and handsome olive-skinned
blackhead woman descended the carriage
steps and threw herself into the waiting
hagrid's arms
it's a shame that maxine was the one
that got away for hagrid but on the
other hand
i think that he was probably the one
that was too good for her what do you
guys think
let me know in the comment section below
until next time
you're a wizard harry